[Musica]
comunicazione dal latino comunicazio
l'enciclopedia treccani mi dice che vuol
dire in senso ampio generico il fatto di
trasmettere ad altro o ad altri per
parlarvi di comunicazione non devo
andare troppo lontano perché anch'io qui
rivolgendomi a voi sto comunicando non
solo attraverso le parole ma soprattutto
tramite i gesti o l'espressione del mio
volto o ancora dagli abiti che decisono
indossare
sono sicura che vi sto comunicando
qualcosa non tanto un messaggio ma forse
un accenno di quello che di cui voglio
parlarvi
per me essere qui a parlare di
comunicazione incredibile perché non
sono mai stata troppo brava ad
esprimermi
infatti penso che la gilda sedicenne o
chiunque non mi abbia vista negli ultimi
tre o quattro anni vi darebbe a sapere
che io sia qui perché non sono mai stata
brava a comunicare infatti per quanto
possa sembrarvi disinvolta adesso nasco
timida da piccola ero una bambina che
arrossiva quando qualcuno gli rivolgeva
la parola o ancora scappava appena
vedeva un volto nuovo è da grandicella
non è che le cose siano migliorate anzi
se pure arrossisci solo in casi di
estremo imbarazzo la mia timidezza si
traduceva in un'eccessiva velocità nel
parlare ai livelli degli speaker degli
spot sui farmaci non so se le vede
presenti che nel momento in cui leggo le
avvertenze ci fanno capire solamente che
il farmaco va tenuto fuori dalla portata
dei bambini il risultato era che non si
capiva niente e poi informando che ho
scoperto che quello che facevo era una
compressione fonica ovvero uno strano
fenomeno per il quale ad un certo punto
del mio discorso
la velocità del parlato aumentava e il
mio tono di voce si abbassava nessuno
riusciva a capirmi magari questa tecnica
poteva essere utile all'interno di uno
spot pubblicitario ma per me era una
tortura tant'è che ad un certo punto
mia madre non mi capiva più e mi
chiedeva se parlassi perché
effettivamente volevo comunicare
qualcosa o perché per qualche strana
ragione volesse far prendere aria alla
bocca e adesso ve ne parlo sorridendo ma
se penso a quella fase della mia vita
qualche problemino ce lo avevo non è che
mi fossi scordata come si parlasse o
come si scrivesse semplicemente ero
incapace di comunicare e voi perché ero
troppo insicura
o forse perché non sapevo neanche io
cosa volevo trasmettere agli altri
perché se è vero che comunicare e
trasmettere nel momento in cui
condividiamo una nostra idea un nostro
pensiero
non stiamo solo e mettendo delle parole
dei suoni ripetendo dei gesti
stiamo consegnando un messaggio agli
altri un po come il messaggio nella
bottiglia che trasportato dalle correnti
del mare da il nome a questo evento
allo stesso modo nel momento in cui ci
rivolgiamo da un'altra persona e come se
consegnassimo una parte di noi stessi
del nostro piccolo strano mondo
all'altro e quindi capite bene che la
comunicazione non è solo una necessità
ma è soprattutto un modo per connetterci
profondamente agli altri e per mostrare
manifestare noi stessi al mondo che ci
circonda non solo la comunicazione può
essere uno strumento di cambiamento
nella misura in cui ci permette di
modellare noi stessi è la realtà che ci
circonda
ed è stato proprio così per me perché
senza alcuna esitazione
posso distinguere nel mio passato un al
gilda nascosta incapace di comunicare è
una gilda manifestata per quanto
esagerato possa sembrarvi il termine
perché proprio questo che mi ha permesso
di fare la comunicazione manifestarmi e
per capire come si è successo voglio
portarvi con me in quarta superiore nei
banchi delle classi del pitagora che
sicuramente tanti ragazzi qui presenti
avranno frequentato è stato proprio lì
che in una giornata come tante
la mia docente di matematica è venuta
con un invito una proposta una sfida
futura cosenza un evento
che poco conoscevo al quale non volevo
partecipare inizialmente ma dopo qualche
esitazione risposi di sì senza
immaginare cosa avrebbe significato per
me rispondere a quella chiamata e così
mi ritrovai nel mezzo di una simulazione
del consiglio regionale della mia
regione la calabria e mi trovai
confrontarmi con altri delegati per
creare un progetto che portasse un
ritorno economico di persone alla nostra
terra e ricordo bene
in quei giorni di dibattito il momento
in cui mi fermai a pensare mi chiesi mi
butto parlo dico quello che ho in mente
è in quel momento mi sentivo come su un
trampolino pronta a saltare da una parte
sentivo l'adrenalina dall'altra il
terrore perché avevo paura di sparare
qualcosa di insensato o di poco
interessante o ancora non credevo di
avere la capacità adeguate per espormi
tanto mi trovavo fronteggiare tutte le
mie peggiori paure ma alla fine decise
di lanciarmi e sentì improvvisamente
tutta la leggerezza di quel salto
ricordo che alla fine di quei giorni
piansi tanto perché ero felice e forse
chi mi guardavano dell'esterno poter
pensare che era una reazione esagerata
solo io sapevo che per me partecipare a
quell'evento non era il semplice
conseguimento di un traguardo non era
solo una partecipazione ma era per me
venire al mondo ovvero riscoprire una
parte di me stessa che non sapevo
esistesse o che forse teneva nascosta
per paura di mostrarla agli altri è
invece in quell'occasione avevo capito
che aveva una voce potevo sentirla e
potevano sentirla anche gli altri
straordinario
in realtà da a partire da quell'evento
sembrava che le opportunità della vita
per me fossero infinite qualche mese
dopo entrai in gue yurt l'associazione
che più ha contribuito alla mia
formazione negli ultimi anni e che mi ha
permesso di crescere e di creare
opportunità di crescita anche per le
persone che incontravo
ad un certo punto alla comunicazione era
diventata per me non qualcosa che
volessi scappare non qualcosa che mi
sentivo a disagio ma era per me così
naturale che avevo trovato la mia
dimensione
e quando parlo di comunicazione e vi
dico che per me comunicare e venire al
mondo pensate un'immagine in particolare
al bambino che stretto nel grembo
materno al sicuro delle brutture del
mondo potrebbe passare lì servito e
riverito il resto della sua vita
eppure quella che gli sembra la
quintessenza della felicità potrebbe
fargli del male perché se il bambino
rimane stelle oltre il termine dei nove
mesi finirebbe per soffocare
e così il bambino è costretto a spingere
affinché possa vedere uno splendore
della vita affinché tramite il parto che
un passaggio traumatico possa bastare da
essere un esserino stretto nel ventre
materno ad un piccolo uomo
il neonato che viene accolto la luce del
mondo e allo stesso modo noi spesso
siamo rinchiusi siamo vittime
all'interno del nostro utero nel nostro
ventre materno fatto di paure rinunce
comodità che ci fanno sentire al sicuro
ma che allo stesso tempo ci impediscono
di vivere è invece dovremmo fare proprio
come donato che spinge per uscire ed è
proprio in questa fatica in questo
trauma che si traduce quella che la
consapevolezza dei servivi il passaggio
dall esistere nel senso strettamente
biologico del termine sopravvivendo
all'essere al mondo chiaramente presente
a se stessi e aperti alle opportunità di
cambiamento che sono sì di rischi ma
sono delle possibilità di crescita
se pensate che la comunicazione sia una
cosa facile mi fermo qui perché anch'io
ad un certo punto della mia vita
pensavo che lo fosse e invece mi sono
ritrovata nel settembre del 2019 assone
pad nuova delhi in india
chiaro che a migliaia di chilometri di
distanza da casa in un contesto
completamente nuovo ma sicuramente
accogliente la comunicazione assumesse
toni completamente nuovi vivaci
stimolanti amy occhi e le mie vecchie
che si ritrovavano a fronteggiare una
nuova sfida dirigere la simulazione del
g20 che anziché tra i grandi del mondo
si sarebbe tenuta con decine di studenti
indiani con i quali non solo dovevo
trattare tematiche complesse quali
l'educazione la sanità ma dovevo farlo
in una lingua di cui monedero padrona in
un contesto completamente nuovo diverso
e soprattutto di quando degli
interlocutori il cui accento era
completamente diverso da quello
accademico qui è abituata e per un
attimo subì la tentazione di voler stare
in un angolino a pensare a tutte le cose
che non sapevo fare ma in realtà quella
quella sfida era così stimolante che
decisi di mettermi in gioco
alla fine per quanto fosse difficile
comunicare proprio per colpa del mezzo
linguistico mi risulta così naturale
parlare con quei ragazzi fu così
stimolante confrontarmi con i loro punti
di vista venire a contatto con le loro
culture o ancora solo ridere e ballare
con loro senza saperlo senza troppe
spiegazioni ci stavamo contaminando cioè
stavamo arricchendo stavamo donando
all'altro qualcosa che lo avrebbe
arricchito per sempre
e tutto questo per un salto nel vuoto o
meglio perché ad un certo punto la paura
di non farcela era stata superata dalla
voglia di mettersi in gioco ed è proprio
questa la chiave di volta per che poi
nel corso della mia vita mi sono
ritrovato ad affrontare tante avventure
che non per forza mi hanno portato a
migliaia di chilometri da casa ma dal
momento in cui mi hanno fatto mettere
piede fuori dall'uscio di casa mi hanno
spinto fuori dalla mia comfort zone e
quindi mi hanno spinto a conoscere nuovi
punti di vista
che forse non mi hanno reso una persona
migliore ma mi hanno portato ad essere
più consapevolmente me stessa e a
connettermi più profondamente con gli
altri tutto questo perché tra la paura
di non sapere cosa dire di non sapere
come dirlo o di dirlo nella maniera
sbagliata
alla fine ho scelto di semplificare le
cose e lo stesso vorrei consigliare a
voi se sentite il bisogno di comunicare
se sentite la voce che vi bussa in gola
perché vuole uscire
se avete dentro un fuoco che brucia non
spegnetelo per paura che divampi ma
alimentate lo alimenta telo giorno dopo
giorno così come facciamo con il nostro
corpo così come le niamo i nostri
muscoli dovremmo allenare nelle nostre
capacità comunicative e per farlo non
serve che qualcuno ce lo insegna non
serve prepararsi basta uscire di casa e
mettersi in gioco anche se non sapete
bene cosa dire e non sapete nemmeno che
dirlo iniziate
parlate
confrontatevi esponete e non lasciatevi
scappare neanche un'opportunità di
comunicare perché magari all'inizio il
massimo che farete sarà dare indicasse
ad uno sconosciuto o raccontare la
vostra giornata ad un gruppo di amici ma
col passare del tempo a furia di
comunicare vi sembrerà così naturale
farlo che a partire dalle piccole sfide
quotidiane riuscirete anche nei contesti
più affollati e da un giorno all'altro
senza che ve ne siete accorti vi
ritroverete protagonisti sul
palcoscenico della vostra vita non vi
resta che iniziare
[Applauso]
[Musica]